conozcamos el teorema del residuo para
polinomios al principio nos va a parecer
un poco mágico pero en un próximo vídeo
lo vamos a probar ya medida que hagamos
ejemplos con este teorema nos vamos a
dar cuenta que como todo en matemáticas
no es tan mágico bien en qué consiste el
teorema del residuo para polinomios
establece que si tenemos un polinomio fx
así es que este de aquí es un polinomio
y lo dividimos
/
/ x menos a entonces el residuo entonces
el residuo el residuo que se obtiene
después de hacer la división larga entre
polinomios el residuo que se obtiene va
a ser igual a efe de a va a ser igual a
efe de a esto que en un principio parece
un poco abstracto estoy hablando de fx
de x menos a hagámoslo más concreto
supongamos que tenemos un polinomio fx y
tomemos un polinomio de segundo grado es
válido para cualquier tipo de polinomios
pero empecemos con uno muy sencillo uno
de segundo grado que es 3x cuadrada
menos 4 x más 7 y supongamos que a es
igual a 1 así es que vamos a dividir
este polinomio vamos a
dividirlo entre
x menos
1 x 1 así es que a en este caso es igual
a 1 hagamos entonces la división larga
de polinomios y si no la conoces o no la
recuerdas te invito a que veas el vídeo
de la división larga de polinomios antes
de continuar con este vídeo voy a
suponer que hacer es hacer ese tipo de
divisiones así es que la división de 3 x
4 menos 4 x 7 entre x menos 1 y verifica
que efectivamente el residuo corresponde
a efe de 1 bien supongo que ya lo
intentaste hagámoslo juntos vamos
entonces a dividir entre x menos 1 el
polinomio vamos a dividir entre x menos
13 x cuadrada menos 4 x más 7 muy bien
una división de polinomios larga no está
mal para empezar el día pues es de
mañana para mí no sé para ti vienen las
divisiones largas nos fijamos en el
término de mayor orden aquí y en el
término de mayor de por acá así es que
tenemos que 3x cuadrada entre x
esto nos da 3x cuadra entre x es igual a
3 x 3 x y lo voy a poner en el lugar
donde se encuentran los términos de
primer orden por así decirlo
entonces 3x x x es 3x cuadrada y 3 x x
menos 1 es menos 3x y esto lo queremos
restar es la manera como se hace la
división larga así es que que obtenemos
3x cuadrada menos 3x cuadrada este
término se cancela este término se hace
cero y por acá tenemos menos 4x más 3x
porque menos por menos es más menos 4 x
3 x es menos x voy a usar otro color
aquí nos queda entonces
- x y voy a bajar este 7 este 7 lo
bajamos esto es muy similar a la
división que aprendimos hacia en
aritmética cuando íbamos en la primaria
tan sólo multiplica de 3x por esto para
obtener 3x cuadrada menos 3x lo cual lo
restamos de aquí para obtener menos x 7
o más bien podríamos decir que lo
restamos del polinomio para obtener
menos x más 7 y ahora tenemos que
dividir entre x menos 1 - x
7 - x entre x es igual a menos uno menos
uno por x es menos x
y menos 1 x menos 1 es más uno pero esto
lo tenemos que restar
hacemos la resta y que nos queda menos x
x esto es menos x mas x estos términos
se cancelan esto es igual a 0 y 7 menos
17 menos 1
esto es igual a 6 el residuo es 6 y una
manera de ver esto es podríamos decir
que podríamos decir que no esto mejor te
lo voy a mostrar en un próximo vídeo así
es que este de aquí es el residuo el
residuo y para saber cuando se tiene un
residuo y éste es tan sólo una revisión
de la división larga es que aquí tienes
un término de un orden inferior este de
alguna manera es un polinomio de grado 0
este es de un orden menor que el
denominador que x menos uno que es de
orden 1 así es que el 6 que podemos
considerar con un polinomio de orden 0
es de un orden menor es el residuo ya no
puede decir 6 entre x menos 1 ahora bien
si se cumple el teorema del residuo para
polinomios y esté aquí es tan sólo un
ejemplo tomado al azar
de ninguna manera una demostración he
desarrollado este problema en concreto
para que podamos verificar de manera
tangible que el teorema del residuo para
polinomios se cumple lo cual quiere
decir en este caso que f
es decir f de 1
efe de uno tiene que ser igual a seis
vamos a verlo efe de uno es igual tres
por uno al cuadrado es tres menos cuatro
por uno menos cuatro más siete
esto es igual 3 - 4 - 17 esto es igual a
6 de hecho es igual a 6 nuestro residuo
y aquí nos merecemos unas pequeñas
fanfarrias así que lo que hemos hecho
aquí es verificar que efectivamente el
teorema del residuo para polinomios
funciona pero lo realmente práctico de
esto es que si alguien nos pide por
ejemplo el residuo de esto 3x cuadra
menos 4 x 7 dividido entre x menos 1 y
no le interesa el cociente entonces lo
que tenemos que hacer en este caso es
identificar que el valor de a es igual a
1 calcular
efe de uno evaluar esto en uno para
obtener que el residuo es 6 no tuvimos
que hacer la división larga sólo tuvimos
que hacer esto para obtener el residuo
así de simple obtuvimos el residuo de
dividir 3 x 4 menos 4 x + 7 entre x
menos 1